and then there's a great moment in bad
boys where michael bay wants you to do
oh yeah and you're you're resisting it
yeah so michael bay he
the fur he did the first bad boys look
how skinny yeah i needed a couple extra
kilos in that thing
um michael bay was the director of bad
boys and it was my first shot at a you
know big movie and he was like dude
i want you to take your shirt off in
this shot you know i was like mike come
on man
it's like
i don't want to take my shirt off and be
you know it is i hate that in action
movies where the guy is all greased up
with his shirt off you know walking
through an abandoned church
dubs acting like that's normal
it's like i don't want to do that he was
like dude you're wrong
you're wrong take your freaking shirt
off
so we ultimately compromised where i
would have my shirt open
and it was a you know a famous scene in
bad boys where i'm running in slow
motion across the bridge with the the
shirt billowing the dolph's behind you
yeah with the dog
he put the doves in and poses
you know but i but i i did that scene
and i remember coming off and
he comes running over to me and he slaps
me in my chest and he says i just made
you a freaking movie star
here's that moment here's how there you
are
there you go
[Music]